[Music]
well every day should be margarita day
but tomorrow marks national margarita
day so we are kicking off the
celebrations with eldorado cantina
joining us today is the general manager
omar villanueva thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me i'm
so excited we're talking margaritas
tequila guacamole it's a fun day
all right we're gonna make a drink here
in a minute but let's talk about what
you guys have planned for tomorrow for
the big national margarita day well
tomorrow's actually a really big day we
have 1940 tuesday and then we also have
national margarita day where we're doing
you know five dollars for regular
margaritas and then eight for all
flavored so it's uh it's gonna be going
on all day so it'll be busy that's so
fun and i just thought about it also
falls on a taco tuesday so it's an
excuse to have tacos as well
all right let's get to it because you
have one margarita here what's this one
in this one this is going to be the
mango margarita okay ooh that's good all
right what are we making here this one
is going to be a raspberry margarita
okay and i'll get it ready for you all
right shaking it up if you don't mind
pouring it for us i would appreciate
that there you go
all right here we go ooh it looks good
okay so this one's raspberry what other
flavors do you have we have passion
fruit uh we have uh our jalapeno
cucumber margarita which is a very
popular one
that's a spicy one that is a spicy one
yes and we can make them all spicy and
we can deviate and change them around
whatever the guest likes well i'm a wimp
so i'm glad we're going for the sweet
one here i'm going to take a sip of this
and as i'm what is along the rim that's
the tahini oh we have tahin salt and
sugar for your rims as well so good okay
cheers happy early national margarita
today i'm taking a sip
whoa
good we did start the party now
okay to go with the margarita you need
something to eat i know i have been to
every el dorado location and your food
is delicious you guys are known for the
guacamole though right a tableside guac
is second to none it's definitely
something you should try when you come
in tacos are great street tacos are
great enchiladas are amazing
and all your food has a little spice to
it so i've learned my lesson but the
great thing about the tableside guac is
you can customize it to whatever you
like right exactly however you want it
if you want extra tomatoes extra
tomatoes if you want extra spice we can
definitely kick the heat up for sure i
like it kick the heat up or you can have
something sweet a little bit of
everything and just a real quick where
can people visit you have you have a
couple locations we have three locations
total we have the one on sammy davis
drive we have the one in tivoli and then
we also have the one in centra on sunset
gosh everything is so good what's your
go-to if i come in like what should i
order um my go-to is always the
enchilada trio because you get one of
each and it's a it's a good try you know
get a little bit of everything yeah you
can't go wrong omar thank you so much
this is delicious i think you should
grab the mango when we do a little
cheers here you earned it you worked
hard
well be sure to go check out el dorado
cantina any day of the year but
especially for national margarita day
look at all those beautiful margaritas
on the screen there that's all three
locations five dollars and eight dollars
for the flavored ones i'm gonna keep
finishing my raspberry one
cheers omar jc i'll send it over to you